reducir la exposición al polvo
radiactivo en el aire atender a las
víctimas que los procedimientos de
descontaminación las autoridades
ucranianas se preparan para lo peor
durante los simulacros de respuesta a
desastres nucleares ensa boricha por
supuesto que estamos preocupados por eso
estamos aquí por eso hemos creado este
grupo la preocupación internacional por
la central eléctrica de savory allá en
el sureste de ucrania ha ido en aumento
desde que fue objeto de bombardeos a
finales de julio tanto kiev como moscú
se señalan mutuamente la mayor
instalación nuclear de europa está bajo
control ruso desde principios de marzo
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg volvió a insistir en los
llamamientos de quiet para
desmilitarizar la zona que rodea el
complejo
[Música]
ahora utiliza en su terreno en torno a
la central nuclear como zona de
operaciones como plataforma para lanzar
ataques de artillería contra las fuerzas
ucranianas y esto es influyente es
irresponsable y no hace sino subrayar la
importancia de permitir las inspecciones
internacionales del gobierno
internacional de energía atómica
y un escenario que -según el presidente-
volodymyr selenski las autoridades
ucranianas podrían atender de inmediato
ucrania está preparada para garantizar
un control adecuado por parte de la oea
y la misión correspondiente puede ser
enviada a la estación de sap orilla de
forma legal muy rápidamente con la mayor
eficacia posible
se espera que sabor y ya esté la agenda
de las discusiones en el oeste de
ucrania en 13 lenski el secretario
general de naciones unidas antonio
guterres y el presidente turco recep
tayip erdogán el jueves